este domingo eminem web tiene lugar una
misa bastante particular en este recinto
completamente lleno de mujeres hombres y
niños todos desplazados la mayoría son
banya mulenga tutsis congoleses y fueron
expulsados de sus pueblos por otras
comunidades
a la salida de la iglesia los cantos y
las oraciones le dan paso a las
recriminaciones tomaron nuestros bienes
nos atacaron incendiaron nuestras casas
hasta hacernos huir y hoy en día somos
refugiados a quien envío nos acusan de
ser ruandeses
pero ni siquiera conocemos ruanda si
fuésemos realmente ruandeses
regresaríamos por decisión propia
no permanecería en esta inseguridad aquí
los banyamulenges son originarios de
ruanda pero muchos están instalados en
los altiplanos de sud kivú desde el
siglo 19 en estas tierras fértiles
ubicadas a 3.000 metros de altura
conflictos relacionados con la
trashumancia oponen a estos ganaderos
con otras comunidades que viven
principalmente de la agricultura a 30
kilómetros de aquí en mi que las
comunidades va bien me va fulero y
bayern jupp perciben a los banyamulenges
como agresores
yo cuando cultivo mis tierras instalo
cercas pero hacen ingresar su ganado
para que destruya todo cuando llegó por
la mañana mi tierra está devastada
cuando voy a hablarles me dicen vamos a
matarte
a siempre sólo la guerra durante los
últimos años las tensiones se agravaron
y las comunidades ahora viven separadas
en mi que en gredos 1750 desplazados van
ya mulenga encontraron refugio en un
campo afuera del pueblo entre los dos se
encuentra una base de la monusco la
fuerza de la onu en la república
democrática del congo los cascos azules
tratan de mediar entre las comunidades
que ya cuentan cada una con grupos de
autodefensa a veces con el apoyo de
países extranjeros en min en web
un miliciano de un grupo manía mulenga
nos acoge en su casa para mostrarnos sus
armas
esta es una bazuca
las dos armas se llaman ak-47 cada grupo
afirma querer defender a su comunidad
pero parece hundirse en un ciclo mortal
de violencia ahora la guerra nos une con
los elementos de miami nos costará mucho
defendernos porque cuentan con armamento
pesado la razón por la cual nosotros
también iniciamos siempre el mismo
proyecto de buscar este tipo de
armamento los conflictos en el altiplano
causaron 128 muertes desde febrero de
2019 según la onu de todas las
comunidades 95 pueblos fueron destruidos
y más de 110.000 personas fueron
desplazadas es en este contexto
exclusivo que fue designado un alcalde
eminem fue el pasado 28 de septiembre
las imágenes suscitaron mucha
indignación algunos acusan el gobierno
de ofrecer tierra a los banyamulenges
para el alcalde su nombramiento y la
creación de la comuna de eminem bueno
siete años antes responden tan sólo a
una necesidad administrativa las
cabeceras de sectores de los territorios
permanecen alejados de la población
la población de eminem estaba de alguna
manera abandonada administrativamente no
es un cantón de manía mulenga es para
todas las comunidades en el congo o como
en bukavu capital de kivú los líderes
comunitarios se preguntan sobre la
oportunidad de dicha instalación
nos quedaremos cruzados de brazos
mientras ahora hay una novedad que está
empeorando la situación en el altiplano
todos reconocen la existencia de
tensiones antiguas entre comunidades
pero muchos denuncian una
instrumentalización política de la
situación se cree y hace de con frío con
minute es cierto había conflictos
comunitarios pero nosotros a nivel de
intercomunitario íbamos allá y
arreglamos las cosas
la instalación de ciertos animadores
impulso a ciertas personas algunos
políticos
a aprovechar la situación para diseminar
mensajes de odio
el estatus de los banyamulenges se
volvió durante los últimos decenios uno
de los principales escollos de la
política congolesa tras haber sido
despojados de su nacionalidad durante
los años 80 muchos jóvenes banyamulenges
se volcaron hacia ruanda en los años 90
uniéndose a la fe pr de paul kagamé y a
las rebeliones de la ahe dl y el rc de
acusadas de crímenes de guerra en el
este de la república democrática del
congo se le reprocha su participación en
estos grupos armados en kinshasa algunos
políticos los acusan de impulsar la
balcanización del país y ven en la
instalación del cantón de mi lengua una
amenaza para la nación la mano de ruanda
está detrás de esto
no lo sé hay una presunción como
congolés permítame decirle que creo que
si no tengo pruebas pero lo siento
el objetivo es desestabilizar el congo
el objetivo es crear las condiciones
para invadir el como como miembro de la
comunidad vania mulenga y antiguo líder
de la rebelión rcd el actual ministro de
la descentralización
azarías ruber ua denuncia por su lado la
estigmatización de la que serían
víctimas los banyamulenges
de banyamulenges el problema son los
manías mulenga
cuando hay generalización son malos son
hacíamos de esta forma
evidentemente usted estigmatice a toda
una comunidad
para desactivar la polémica el
presidente félix si se quería anunció en
octubre la suspensión de la instalación
del cantón de eminem web pero en el
altiplano los disparos se escuchan casi
todas las noches